for months now the parents movement has
gained steam all around america storming
school board meetings exposing radical
teachers even deciding the virginia
gubernatorial election
but just as these normal moms and dads
think that they are hitting their stride
the peak of their powers
one teacher has taken to tick-tock to
give everyone a reality check
so i see how you think that you've done
something here because
parents or community members have voiced
concern
to their elected official which is how
the process works
um
not not bringing it to a teacher right
they're taking it to the elected
official
and now that uh legislators are are
trying to implement these things um but
still in fact a parent
not my boss
i don't i don't actually
answer to them so
get bent
so get bent so
arrogant
so
radical
so
obviously correct
yes we can complain to our
representatives about radical racial and
sexual ideologies in the classroom yes
we can go viral at school board meetings
and even win some of those seats for
ourselves yes
we can even occasionally get a
particularly insane educator put on i
don't know administrative leave
but the radicals still run the schools
they still run the classrooms and the
administrations and the teacher unions
and the training sessions and the
curricula and just about everything else
in the education system
they've got
real power and they intend to hold on to
that power no matter what we do at the
school board meetings or at the ballot
box
these radicals who are raising our kids
don't think parents are their bosses
because right now at least
we're not
i'm glad you like that clip you know
what you can do to get more clips you
can ring the bell subscribe to the
michael knowles show if you're not
getting notifications for whatever
reason youtube head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]